Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
The Loki people have been posting more deleted
scenes and alternate endings to the series.
Some of them are radically different takes on
what God Loki winds up turning into
in how he controls the multiverse
now, like he looks way more powerful
in some of these deleted scenes,
like the most powerful character in all the MCU.
So we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes we have.
What if season two coming up?
some of the deleted scenes
actually look like they're based on the what
if series We're also doing that giveaway for the Loki
Blu rays.
Mandalorian There's a bunch of Blu rays
that they're finally making for the Disney Plus series.
All you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and just post all your theories
about what you want Loki to be doing next in the MCU.
on them.
A couple giveaway winners during this video too,
careful for spoilers.
If you have not seen the Loki finale yet,
I think most people have seen it by now.
But. At the end of the finale, per the Loki producers
in the Marvel people, Loki chose to try and beat
he who remains in escape his design of the multiverse
that he was calling the sacred timeline
and break free from the time loop
controlled by the loom, by literally breaking the loom.
doing so causes all the timelines of the entire
multiverse, like the wider multiverse, to start dying.
And he uses his newly unlocked power
as God of stories, Loki
to re-energize the timelines and keep them alive,
binding them all together in what becomes
a cosmic representation of the true world tree
as it's meant to exist in the MCU.
like a higher depiction than we saw during Thor,
the Dark World, then sitting on the remains of he
who remains citadel at the end of time as consisting
of the Marvel Universe, as the Loki producers call him.
that's how they're affectionately
referring to his new role in the MCU.
They're saying that he's
meant to be based on the god of stories.
Loki And they're just calling him God.
Loki So you can call him whatever you want,
but this is meant to be his true
God form that he was always destined to achieve,
God of mischief.
Loki was always meant to be like a lesser form,
like a lesser version of the character
before this evolution, before he unlocked his true
God of stories power inside himself to manipulate time.
as you would expect with any Marvel movie
or TV series like this is true for all of them.
There were a number of alternate endings
and deleted scenes, a lot of different ideas
that they had for Loki's ending during the series,
and he remains and what his powers would be basically
the first
major one you may have seen recently
is what looks like Loki turning into more
of a watcher type of character,
not becoming the actual watcher like Uatu.
but basically it amounts to the same thing,
like the same type of role
that he would watch over the multiverse.
it's no coincidence that we have the
what if season two episodes
also happening in a couple of weeks I'll do videos
for all those episodes when they do release.
but originally they were supposed to release
what if season two before Loki Season two.
So I think behind the scenes
they were initially figuring out what Loki's new powers
were going to be and how they were going to work,
and they were using the watcher as a template for that,
like the What if series in general
with the way he handles the multiverse
if it wasn't clear the
what if series is a different part of the multiverse,
but it is canon to the larger MCU in the same way
that Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man, Andrew Garfield's
Amazing Spider-Man universe,
Tom Hardy's Venom Universe are all canon to the MCU now
That's why you see a lot of similar looking characters
like Captain Carter
or Doctor Strange Supreme
appearing in the live action movies.
but notice this scene of watcher Loki,
as we'll call him for the purposes of this video,
his power manifests the same type of cosmic energy
that the watcher gives off.
That's called the Kirby Crackle effect.
It's a visual style created by Jack Kirby
during the original Fantastic Four comics,
and it's meant to depict cosmic energy
and it looks like his entire body
was meant to evolve into a more cosmic form.
Like his whole body
is radiating this cosmic energy effect.
He almost seems way more powerful
as this version of the character than in the final cut.
Kind of the way that you see the watcher
appearing in all the what if episodes
the way he sort of blends
in with the fabric of the multiverse.
like, the way that all the regular characters in the
what if episodes existing in the third
dimension look up in outer space
and see his sort of outline amongst the stars.
I think the idea is
that Loki would be a little bit more like this.
they also use this Kirby Crackle effect during the
what if episodes when the Watchers fighting Infinity
Ultron in the Spider-Man into the Spider-Verse
across the Spider-Verse people also used it
in both those movies to depict the super collider
when it was breaching the multiverse.
Notice the crystalline structures here too.
It also looks like they plan to depict the multiverse
in the Loki finale,
the different timelines
to look more like the watchers base during
what if in the way that they depict the multiverse
during that series, ages it's way more crystalline.
as opposed to the ropes
that they used during the final episodes of Loki.
I think the ropes as timelines work
a little bit better within this representation.
It also helps clarify that Loki is in
a higher dimension when this is happening, and that's
why he's able to perceive timelines as physical robes
and he can actually reach out and grab them He's
literally grabbing time and that wouldn't be possible
unless you were in a higher dimension.
It also explains how the watcher exists
in his little space here, like his little base
is a pocket dimension of itself
that exists above the normal MCU timeline.
the next deleted scene from the Loki
finale is actually in this part here.
After he's decided to try and beat he
who remains in his own game
instead of breaking the loom
like he did in the final cut in this deleted version,
he would have totally fixed the loom,
then ascended to the same throne that he created
for himself out of the remains of
he who remains citadel at the end of time.
this is the very obvious reason why they get rid of
that was because it kind of didn't make sense, like
it didn't work thematically with what
Loki was trying to do, like he was trying to beat he
who remains at his own game
by not playing into his game in the whole idea
is that he who remains wanted to preserve the loom
because it kept his stranglehold on the multiverse.
so if Loki had fixed that at the end of the finale,
then ascended the throne,
it just wouldn't have made sense.
then probably one of the crazier endings
that they had originally planned for the series
goes back to before they decided
to make he who remains a king variant.
So this is before they decided to make Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty to use Kang the Conqueror
as the main villain of Ant-Man and the WASP Quantumania
Originally, during the Loki finale,
they had cast Jonathan Majors to play
He who remains in.
They started the series planning to reveal
that he who remains was just another Loki variant
that looked like Jonathan Majors
play the Agatha all along theme song.
Again, it was Loki all along
some of you might have had this theory
during Loki season one,
like maybe he's just another Loki in disguise.
But it wasn't till after Jonathan Majors performance
in his original scenes
that they decided to make he who remains a Kang variant
instead an upgrade
to sort of an Avengers level threat
like turned into this big council of Kangs thing.
It also might come as a surprise to know that
they originally did not plan to make a Loki season two.
That's why Loki season two kind of feels like
it could just be episodes seven and eight of Loki.
Season one.
if you think about it
not a lot happens during the events of Loki Season two.
In fact, you could actually speedrun those first couple
of episodes and then just have that final episode.
is Tom Hiddleston explains that it was always
their intention to eventually get Loki to this moment
here, but when they started, they weren't going to do
multiple seasons of Disney Plus shows.
That's why the original showrunner
didn't come back for Loki.
Season two, because Marvel didn't decide to do it
till like way after the series was done
and she'd already moved on to another job
because she needed more work.
bye now.
You've all heard about all the chaos behind Marvel.
They've delayed a lot of stuff happening in 2024.
They've completely changed the way they do.
Their marvel TV series.
part of the reason for that is because they decided
this whole six episode event series
just was not working for them
as a business model in general.
so what they're doing now is focusing on making fewer
shows
overall, making them more quality, longer
episode runs in.
Part of the reason for that is the idea
that they might actually license some of these Disney
Plus shows to other networks in other networks
can insert traditional ad breaks like a normal hourlong
episode of TV that you would watch on broadcast
television back in the day.
post all the memes.
It's been 84 years
since we watched traditional broadcast TV
on a normal TV network
that's basically where streaming television is headed.
Like we're headed back to the way television
used to be, but just delivered digitally instead.
Right now, the best example of that,
a marvel behind the scenes is Daredevil, born again.
Like they kind of canceled what they were originally
doing with the series and they've rebooted it again.
But it was going to be 18 episodes in season one,
like a traditional TV
season
used to be up to like 20, 22 episodes per season.
part of the reason for that
is because they're kind of shifting towards
that model of the Marvel Disney Plus series.
But there's obviously a lot in the future
they haven't announced yet.
There are a couple of series they haven't released yet
that were made under the old method.
We'll find out about what's going on
in the next couple of years, though.
Generally, their focus now is on doing less
but doing more quality projects
just in general between the movies and the TV series.
So I think that's good news all around.
being able to license their shows to other networks
also gives them way
more money
making the series much more sustainable long term, too.
Because Disney, if you didn't realize,
is losing a ton of money on Disney
plus It's the same for all the other big streamers too.
Even Netflix doesn't make as much money as you think.
the couple of the Loki videos that I'm working on
because they've already revealed
that they plan on reuniting it with Thor.
They're making Thor five.
Apparently they plan on having Loki in Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty, Secret Wars.
there's a lot of stuff happening
behind the scenes in there.
A couple other related trailers
that they dropped recently.
So I'll try to do videos for everything
as quickly as possible.
make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Congratulations.
STEM 2049 and Red's Wasted Talents.
You're the giveaway winner from my last big Loki video.
Please email me on the about page of my channel
so we can get your contact details.
Click here for my Loki Season
three video and click here for that brand new Marvel.
What if season two trailer video episodes
for that starting really soon.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!